à la rencontre de thibaut un jeune
ferronnier d'art en travaillant à
l'ancienne comme les anciens il a lu le
savoir faire traditionnel aux nouvelles
technologies un travail rare et
recherchée qui permet à cet artiste de
vivre aujourd'hui de sa passion waouh ça
va être un vrai talent y va eh ben dis
donc tu en paies d'action la whey est là
ça va pas tarder vraiment c'est chira
points donc tu as tes qui paie tout de
suite faute d'accord vous le bien ce
tablier boules quiès indispensable
j'imagine elle vaut mieux lui au mieux
ok mais là je vais tout de suite
et quand il sait qu'il est bon là c'est
allé passer à la voilà la couleur quand
il est blanc on appelle ça le blond
soudan justin autres sont en fusion
battus pour le travail et il va être
tendre ça va être le bon moment tendre
comme dans divers comme c'est parti
sa forme
je suis né je suis c'est de faire une
belle poids sa soixante deux étapes
cette forme là
est ce qu'on va obtenir la fin c'est ça
c'est ça tu vas obtenir ouais d'accord
moi y'a encore du boulot
sa musique est très physique ah oui
c'est sûr que quand c'est le martelage
sur des constructions c'est intensif
après moi j'ai pas de marteau pilon
toi tu fais tout à la main tout à la
main qu'est ce que tu aimes dans dans le
set de marteler comme ça c'est le
contact la matière et puis c'est pour
faire vraiment ce qu'on veut peut
arriver à n'importe quelle forme
c'est sans limite
l'ag carte nos matières
[Musique]
il faut que j'arrive à la même forme que
les autres donc il faut vraiment que
j'écarte encore là pour obtenir la même
chose j'ai encore du travail pour toi ça
m'épate également c'est à dire tous
veulent reproduire à l'identique il est
forfait identique et jusqu'à la lie
puisque c'est pas ça
[Musique]
ok bon nathalie à ton tour maintenant tu
que j'essaye à tu vas essayer on va
partir sur une section un petit peu plus
bas et la voix de rêve quand on voit la
différence de taille
mais pour commencer je te je préfère à
aller tu le mets dans le feu attention
rolala le ballon va regarder à tuer là
c'est déjà chose c'est parti tu enlèves
un gant dans l'est ont besoin de frappe
voilà tu emmènes là bas voilà voilà
anton marteau essaye vraiment d'aller au
bout si tu peux oh moi tu peux
reconnaître que je vise juste oui prêt à
tourner à car allah tournant car peuple
a déjà épuisé
j'aimerais que tu montres ça paraît
tellement simple quand c'est toi qui
fait avaler un petit peu mieux
je suis content d'avoir essayé quand
même tu vois cette tête juste cet
ensemble la tuer mais combien de temps
pour le faire
alors c'est tout un ensemble mais on va
dire que pour cette tête c'est à dire
deux heures mais comment tu ta ta pas de
plantu fait corriger par l'armée voilà
j'ai des plantes définition et puis là
donc c'est notre crois qu'on est en
train de faire avec nos dimensions
c'est à dire que quand tu rencontres le
client tu fais un croquer avec lui pour
être d'accord sur le dessin danse par un
dessin à la main ouais crayon de bois et
après donc après voilà il ya une
définition générale 3d qui se fait même
mois pour la fabrication je gagne du
temps après je mets cote mais tu fais
également des sculptures monumentales en
métal j'aimerais bien les voir et ben
écoute on va les voir ça allez c'est
parti
c'est un diable c'est sa démission
et oui il fait son effet sa taille il
fait son volume et sont coiffés
ça c'est quoi ces crues ça c'est du
forget voilà donc les mains il est parti
fort j'ai les mains les doigts les
ongles après tout le reste donc c'est un
saint squelette en quarts et de 25 comme
on a travaillé tout à l'heure le gros
carrés et un squelette les tôles
martelait qui sont plaquées par dessus
donc martelé à l'enclume aussi à froid
et qui sont bloqués par dessus et soudé
ça c'est une pièce qui est casher à ton
coeur bat ce qui a marqué notamment au
lancement on le début de mon activité à
mon compte
quand j'ai commencé voilà c'était ma
pièce maîtresse évidemment et ça m'a
permis d'avoir la de présenter sur des
salons et d'avoir des premières
commandes et pouvoir démarrer grâce à
lui justement à quel âge tu as su que tu
veux devenir ferronnier d'art et comment
t'es venue cette passion c'est mon père
qui ont montré comment soudés comme
j'avais j'étais au collège et au riche
de collèges avec 20 14 13 ans et j'étais
tout jeune mais je me suis fait un buggy
pour couler dans les chocs et donc à la
soudure etc
avec un moteur de voiture est et c'est
un petit peu partir de là que j'ai su
que c'était voilà que c'était une façon
jamais fabriqué à tanger monsigna
mécanicien gens provenant mécanicien la
future à la ferronnerie d'art c'est venu
encore après c'est que j'ai commencé par
être chaudronnier donc vraiment
travailler en atelier puis j'ai changé
d'entreprise j'ai passé donc une
entrevue ce qui faisait aussi des
portails un petit peu de ferronnerie et
c'est ça qui m'a donné le goût j'ai
commencé à faire des rampes à des choses
travaillées stylisé et s'est élancée de
cette déviation l'acquis et qui a fait
que je me suis mis à mon compte
notamment en tant que ferronnier
mollement un peu de tes réalisations
active ou alors la lande sur château
gaillard qui a travaillé pour eux j'ai
travaillé là bas j'ai fait 60 m de
garde-corps voilà comment ça se passe
t'il vais aller voir avec son mac est
alors voilà dans un premier temps une
ébauche qui se fait en plan
main un crayon de papier après dans un
second temps je vais les une 3d qu'on va
affiner avec le client donc voilà sur le
pc on peut en général à des dimensions
qui change un petit peu et voilà une
placement de la bague et sont des photos
de la rambarde
donc on a tout le tout la partie rampe
de belvédère et là c'est sûr sur la
terrasse l'ensemble n'est qu'un accord
sur la terrasse travaille
essentiellement pour des monuments
classés comme comme ce château où les
particuliers j'ai beaucoup de
particuliers des portails voilà des
rampes d'escalier des garde-corps j'ai
la chance d'avoir des commandes assez
variées vous et lancer des défis alors
ça mais moi je te souhaite bonne chance
pour la suite des aventures merci hélas
le plaisir de découvrir ton ton univers
salut travailler merci c'est un plaisir
partagé
vous l'avez vu thi boumahni l'aimé telle
perfection
encore un bel exemple de sa partie